parmi les 100 familles qui se rendent au
resto du cœur de Montlouis 57 sont
bénéficiaires du revenu de solidarité
active c'est le cas de Daniel 60 ans
ouvrière elle a été licenciée il y a 20
ans et depuis n'a jamais retrouvé
d'emploi stable aujourd'hui Danielle vit
avec 700 € par mois grâce au RSA et à
une allocation logement un budget minime
pourrait laisser de filles également au
chômage j'arrive toujours à payer ce que
les ce qui est à payer comme le DF le
tout ça mais c'est vrai que à côté quand
tu vas acheter les petits trucs je ne
peux pas là là le gaz va encore
augmenter et puis tout ça je peux pas
mettre de l'archamp de côté pas du tout
j'arrive pas j'ai toujours un peu de
découvert tout ça sur mon C je m'achète
rien pour moi j'achète plus pour mes
filles que pour moi alors voyez moi
voyez je porte des affaires que j'ai
depuis un certain temps que mes filles
bon ils ont toujours des un peu
d'affaires qu'on leur donne lorsqu'on
évoque la hausse du RSA Daniel sourit
mais nous confie que quelques euros
supplémentaires ne changeront pas son
quotidien une position que partage bon
nombre d'associations d'aide aux
personnes en situation précaire 2 % tous
les ans sur 5 ans ça fait 10 % même si
on y ajoute l'inflation éventuelle et ça
reste à voir qu'est-ce que ça va faire
on est même pas au demi SMIG qui était
prévu
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec un Smig
actuellement aujourd'hui en indréloire
un peu moins de 30000 personnes sont
bénéficiaires du RSA c'est 3,7 % de plus
qu'en 2011 Z